-So is this --
This is it?
You're not gonna...
say anything?
-Anyone's invited to speak,
but I'm okay with silence.
-So no icebreakers or...
-I, for one, I'm missing work,
not to mention I left Edward
home with my husband,
which is basically like leaving
a 12-year-old boy alone
with a man who I love dearly,
but is also essentially
a 12-year-old.
-Oh, hold up.
Did you say
a 12-year-old boy named Edward?
Is it the Edward?
Just putting two and two
together here.
-Are you the aunt?
-Yeah.
Yeah, that's me.
I guess I'm the aunt.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here
with Taylor Schilling.
That was a clip
from "Dear Edward."
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is very --
It's a very beautiful show.
Very challenging material.
-Yeah.
-Deals with a tragedy.
Also, very uplifting.
-Yeah.
Yeah.
You know, I think this show
is really a celebration
of the moments that we have to
start over, which, I mean, I --
I can relate to.
I feel like those --
kind of those moments
where you're like, "Okay.
I really thought life was gonna
be going in this direction,
and I thought
I was gonna land here,
but I kind of wake up,
and I'm over here."
And the process
of embracing reality.
-You have a co-star
in this who is wonderful.
Is his name Colin O'Brien?
-Yes.
-And he's 14 years old.
-And, is it --
I mean, I'm always taken when --
I mean, I'm assuming --
He seems like he knows exactly
what he's doing.
-Mm-hmm.
-And as an actor...
-He does.
-...is it, like, intimidating,
at times, to be with, like,
a younger actor
who knows what they're doing
so well?
-I think so.
I mean, I think it's
mostly intimidating
that he knows --
he knows so intensely
what he's doing.
And we -- we end,
and he pivots to, you know,
rocks or lava
or talking about the layers
of sediment in the planet.
[ Laughter ]
And then naming them and asking
if he can quiz me on them.
-Yeah. Aren't you excited
about those quizzes?
-I'm like, "I have to focus."
[ Laughter ]
"Give me a minute."
But, I mean, I knew more --
But I knew more about rocks
and things...
-Oh, so that's great.
-...when we were over.
-So you came out of
this whole process
both with a wonderful show
and some rock knowledge.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Which you've always
been looking for.
-I have.
[ Laughter ]
-Every time you're here,
I remember, you know,
people always say,
"What do you guys talk about
during the commercial breaks?"
and I'm always like,
"Have you learned anything
about rocks?"
and you're always like, "No."
[ Laughter ]
Now I have,
thanks to Colin O'Brien.
I've learned about rocks.
He's a very,
very talented actor.
He's very diligent,
very rigorous.
-That's fun to be around.
-It is.
-You -- I'm very jealous
of another actor
that you are friends with.
And I think this friendship
has bloomed
since the last time I saw you.
-Mm-hmm.
-You're friends with Jane Fonda.
[ Cheers ]
That's really good.
Taylor, that's really good.
-I know.
I mean, I don't know how --
I don't know how.
I'm very, very lucky.
Jane, uh --
I am, and Jane is -- Jane's a
real role model for everyone.
She -- Jane has taught me,
you know,
we need to send thank-you cards.
And she never --
Jane remembers everything.
And for exa--
I mean, she's already,
with all of the things
she's doing, she sends notes,
you know, sharing her excitement
for my projects.
-[ Laughs ]
-And I'm grateful to her.
I don't know.
You know.
-It's really amazing when you
meet someone like Jane Fonda,
who, just their work alone,
would be impressive.
-Yes.
-And then you also learn
how to be a better human being.
You're like, "Oh, man, I must be
really dropping the ball."
[ Laughter ]
-It doesn't fully --
It doesn't fully make sense.
But I feel like, you know,
she's one of those people
that, inside of her sphere,
everybody's better.
-Yeah.
-You're just -- everybody takes
it up a notch.
-You get a little closer
to Jane Fonda,
and you just are like --
-You're better.
-"This is
the best version of me."
-Yeah, it's like some filter
on your phone but on your soul.
-Has she met Tank?
-No, no.
-That's for the best.
I think that's for the best.
-Tank -- it's for the best.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what Tank would do.
And Tank can't fly.
-I think you have a very special
thing going with Jane,
and I don't think you should
bring Tank into the mix.
-No, we don't need to.
[ Laughter ]
-I just feel like
this is a situation where Tank
could only make it
a little bit worse.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I think you're right.
-Congratulations on the show.
Thanks for being here.
-Thank you.
-It's always so great
to see you.
-Thank you for having me.
-Taylor Schilling.
New episodes of "Dear Edward"
are available Fridays
on Apple TV+.
We'll be right back
with Eddie Izzard.